Welcome to our form 2 agriculture
digital content agriculture is an
important subject in our day-to-day life
in form one you were introduced to both
crop and livestock practices in form two
you will continue broadening the content
scope using the following topics
inorganic fertilizers planting crop
plants Nursery practices field practices
vegetables production livestock
parasites livestock Health livestock
nutrition you will also Al have the
opportunity to practice some Hands-On
skills in answering examination
questions as a preparation for the
subject
evaluation welcome and enjoy all the
activities in form 2 agriculture digital
content hi guys if this is the first
time you've come to my Channel please go
down the bottom hit that subscribe and
turn on all notifications so you can get
notified every time I post a brand new
video similar to this keep
watching